bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors est ce que cette
présidentielle ouvre une nouvelle page
politique en equateur bonjour et
l'élection présidentielle est assez
important puisque le peuple équatorien
va devoir choisir
en gros c'est un projet de continuité
avec les politiques actuelles du
gouvernement c'est à dire des politiques
néolibérales d'austérité de réforme du
trait de libéralisation du travail de
précarisation etc qui surtout incarné
par le candidat de droite
guillermo olaso ou une rupture on va
dire post néo libérale de 2d politique
actuelle du gouvernement qui a incarné
par andré saragosse et au milieu il ya
un troisième homme
il ya que perez du mouvement pachakutik
qui essaie justement de se placer au
delà de ces deux candidatures dans une
dans une posture qu'on pourrait appeler
de postes politiques en évitant tous les
conflits en parlant à la fois enfin
poubelle je dirais même surtout à la
droite mais aussi en reprenant les
revendications de gauche de son de son
mouvement
et quel est le bilan si on peut faire un
bilan du mandat de la lenin moreno le
bilan il assez simple il a été il a fait
tout le contraire de du programme sur
lequel il avait été élu il
venu à une politique néolibérale en
signant en plus avec un accord avec le
fonds monétaire international
il ay là il a changé complètement tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est en rapport avec les institutions il
a tout changé on ne peut pas ce niveau
là donc en gros une augmentation de la
pauvreté une augmentation de la
précarisation de la du travail
l'élimination de dison de subsides pour
les hauts niveaux de l'essence à tirer
après le grand problème en fait de ce
gouvernement c'est que quand même temps
qui diminuait le poids de l'état comme
acteurs économiques
il a aussi diminué le l'action d'état
c'est à dire que pendant
comme on voit dans tous les pays du
monde l'action l'état est important dans
cette période de pandémie
le gouvernement équatorien a décidé au
delà des mesures d'interdiction de
prohibition de quasiment tout tout ce
qu'on préfère en equateur le
gouvernement a décidé de ne pas
gouverner cette pandémie
c'est à dire qu'il est en fait les
villes et les villes prendre des mesures
au niveau local et au niveau national le
gouvernement ne gouverne pas c'est assez
étonnant comme comme situation mais en
tout
c'est la situation via la période
d'austérité n'a pas changé même dans la
santé alors que on avait besoin d'une
dune grande d'un grand investissement
dans la santé publique tout le compteur
a été fait même ils ont viré des des
médecins dans la santé publique dans les
hôpitaux publics pendant cette pandémie
donc on va dire une gouvernement qui ne
gouverne pas l'urgence la pandémie mais
qui continuent d'appliquer le programme
d'une famille un programme très bon
libéral qui va à l'encontre des droits
sociaux à l'encontre des droits du
travail quelle sera la priorité de celui
qui va être élu redresser l'économie du
pays
il ya deux priorités
premièrement gérer la crise la crise
sanitaire
et ça ça va passer autant par un
investissement urgents dans la cité dans
la santé publique mais aussi par un plan
de vaccination pour toute la population
est aussi l'investissement dans des
tests etc et en même temps oui enfin il
faut gérer la crise économique social
jogger bon ils font complètement
changer les politiques économiques de
bon sens la honda salon propose de de
sortir du de l'accord avec le fmi
guillermo là sont au contraire veulent
rester et jakub ps en gros dit il va
falloir négocier
voilà bon c'est des choix évidemment de
ses choix idéologiques de politiques
publiques qui sont très importants pour
la population sachant que 83% de la
population aidantes et aidants des
situations soient de chômage soit de
sous-emploi d'emplois précaires
donc le prochain président va affronter
une situation très difficile
ça ne va pas être évident et en même
temps il va y avoir une situation assez
difficile au niveau de la
gouvernementalité puisque aucun de ces
candidats aura une majorité absolue au
parlement donc il va falloir faire en
plus des négociations avec d'autres
d'autres partis etc
c'est une situation en fait très
difficile en ce moment en equateur quel
que soit le prochain président matthieu
le quang mairie en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur en sciences
politiques et spécialiste de l'équateur
martienne